hey guys so we just had our cars broken
into basically we were ten minutes we
were gone for about ten minutes we were
just away with in line of served the
cars and someone came over smashed the
windows stole laptop wallet keys Amy's
bag with her very important stuff in it
like all of her cards her house keys
stuff like that laptop's gone paperwork
gone cars were locked and we were within
earshot of it we should have heard
windows breaking and yet we didn't so
that's just that's just is what it is so
we were gonna film another video today
but now we got to follow up on this
because we've already filed the police
reports we've already contacted the
place all the cards are cancelled all
the banks have been contacted we
actually know what store they tried to
use the card at so we're trying to they
have security footage and that they do
so because we know that the LAPD are
going to be slow about it we're gonna
try to really hound people to get this
stuff because there's very little chance
that we'll get it back but there is a
chance if we're quick about it because
we with security footage you can get
there already compiling a report on the
faces of them we just need to hand the
police to be able to do that so LA PD
we're gonna be bothering you today so
that'll be good
right guys right okay so just there's a
lesson to learn about all of this if you
got valuables don't keep them in your
car even if it's locked up because
people ya don't lock it because then
they won't smash your window so yeah
just don't keep valuables in there at
all and you won't have your stuff stolen
and have to deal with this all day get
cards replacing all that stuff and I'll
have a good time so if there's any other
informational blurbs to let you guys
know about this I will keep you updated
butter than that I'm gonna be focusing
on this for the time being so uh we'll
make that happen
all right see you guys you have a good
one
[Laughter]